hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Wario's now I didn't expect as many
people to want this as there were the
first part was actually really popular
and I didn't intend to play it again
because you know I I didn't want to play
too many of these five nights at
Freddy's clones when five nights at
Freddy's 3 was already on the way and by
the way if you haven't seen them already
here are the teaser images that came out
Wow everything was going down and I
totally forgot how to play oh yeah
that's right I'm on 93 peach just came
out I don't need to listen to you man I
don't need to I need to survive a night
so shut up I got busy skip thank you now
I think that as soon as I skip times
actually have times actually gonna start
going these guys are gonna start popping
up so I just need to be wary very wary
what's going on because things got a
little oh hey I remember your gigantic
there why are you so big no one has ever
asked that before in the history forever
but why well I forgot we got this game's
eggs
I've got this game Jackson kind of
creepy I forget if there's actually a
reason that I need to check the the I
heard a goddamn step you step out there
but I forget if there was actually a
reason and I need to check the the
camera there by the way it is very very
cold in this room right now I turned on
the air conditioning and the grump
recording on the air conditioning works
it's cold and comfortable in my
surroundings I think things are trying
to kill me all the gay not all the gay
not all the gays okay gonna move on now
yeah I was actually shocked about when I
was playing this game like the first two
nights it seemed really mellow and it
seemed really uneventful I mean I don't
know what to expect you got that squeaky
squeak how in the hell did you record a
noise like that
okay so that answers one problem and I
guess it creates another problem but at
least it solves one
[Music]
oh yeah the squeaky that's the door what
the hell why are you back I just closed
that is did I leave the light on oh yeah
God I'm gonna run out of power this time
I don't even know if Luigi's shown his
face yet god damn house the noises are
not okay in this game go away Wario go
away okay that's bad he's gonna hang
around there for a while isn't he
[Music]
I don't like this there's a bunch of
Bologna
you're just gonna come popping back and
forth he's totally like Barney right now
Barney
my voice would stop cracking for a
little bit oh there's Luigi so what's
with the clang keys I see you there
don't think you're being a sneaky back
there
he's gone god I need to save power they
really been killing me this time I don't
I do not know if I actually need to look
at the cameras most of the time I think
that I'd actually be okay but I'm not
sure that sounds like someone's walking
in heels is peach are coming that's not
a euphemism again don't misconstrue my
words God whenever I pop out of the
screen it defaults me over to the right
side so I need to learn to cuz I mean
every five nights at freddy's game i've
always defaulted to look into the left
first and there's been bad there's been
good reason for that okay okay what's
with the heels you gonna do something
you're just gonna mess with me I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get through this baby that
ain't good gotcha God if I miss that but
now I'm gonna have a rough time we're
easy to this click on the son of a [ __ ]
hi how are you maybe I shouldn't stare
at you I mean just does a habit I don't
mean to
okay turn it off Damon the clicking is
not very accurate in this game speech
still there
nope it's moved on we just back up over
there I'm just gonna check more
frequently because that'll happen
they're gonna come after me not okay
with it
sorry I got drop my voice down a little
bit because I've been using it a lot
today clicks please mansion before this
Spooky's House of jump-scares you peach
I hear you peach goddamn I forget I I
don't recall if people actually listed
out that this was part of an actual
Mario creepypasta I believe someone said
yes but I didn't read it myself so I
can't exactly confirm that to be true
I'm just gonna close my doors until 6:00
a.m. if that's all right with everybody
else I think I'm gonna be good until the
end just gonna ride this one out
yeah I didn't even need to all right so
I was named three I'm gonna roll right
in the night for see if I can beat that
one I don't know what's going on here
but I'm gonna find out more about the
story very soon it's so cold that window
is too much like the we're doing the
game ah okay what do we got call me up
call me up buddy I'm ready
give me so Laurie sorry my voice is
totally gone any minute now
Wow well this is your fortnight
I think that you can take tomorrow and
the rest of next week Alf we have the
company here have decided to close the
factory out for a little while some
things has been going on the machines
keep turning on and off and I seem to
constantly be some kind of glitch in the
system
and yesterday an employee found well two
teeth in the basement so we have weird
things has been going on oh we're zone
we decided to close it off at least for
a while one could think that there are
some intruders trying to get the secret
recipe if you didn't know Wario and
Waluigi had a secret recipe that I'm
sure many people and they're just
leaving yeah apparently Wario and
Waluigi ran a little shop or something
before this factory was opened and
should be very hard for any thieves to
get into the factory oh if you haven't
noticed this Factory has two entrances
both of those entrances are heavily
locked so any intruder getting in should
be impossible I'm speaking of intruders
and people inside a factory you haven't
heard any voices or some kind well as I
was leaving my day shift yesterday I
could swear I heard a voice coming from
inside a factory said something like
stop him and help me or something I
don't know though because it really
sounded like that Luigi gah he went
missing
so anyways just get through these lights
and you will probably have a day off
tomorrow we'll send you a letter in the
mail sounds great but not out for
something
you show anyways good luck and I'll talk
to you tomorrow
what what am I not telling me la canal
told you tomorrow again you said that
you you literally just said that why did
you say that twice is this something I
should read into about that okay are
these guys not getting like what I'm
telling them at night when I see ghosts
I see monsters in the darkness I mean
even if they didn't believe me I would
freaking quit there's other jobs in real
fast food restaurants that you that
would probably be better than this one
the only motivation I can understand is
that this one would pay halfway decently
and I mean they did discover like after
after a while the reason the pay seems
so low in the five nights at Freddy's
game is because that was actually a clue
to the time what is that that happened
again before what the hell is that some
windows thing happening over here don't
be running towards me what we g9 that
Pete's clip-clopping towards me for
their heels I wanna I wanna I want to
look more around because I do want to
see what it has offer me in terms of
like the storytelling of the environment
and I want to get that but oftentimes I
think I can't why do I have audio in the
bathroom what could I possibly want to
hear coming from ghosts in the bathroom
I saw that damn it damn it I saw that I
see you there Luigi you think you're
hiding from me you're not a clever thing
I have to say it this moment so just
let's not machinery whoa hi mark what
wait is he there
waiting there hear that pundit
hi okay this is some freaky [ __ ] I'm
gonna joke about that that was some
freaky [ __ ] that was a little itty bitty
Mario on the computer over there
Bob sweat Oh God there he is again what
do I do
oh god he's getting closer
wait he's getting bigger about that okay
okay okay what do I do about you
no thank you
[Music]
okay welcome to the party doo dah dah
dah dah dah noodle washbasin god damn it
why is faceless Mario on my computer
right now da da do-do-do-do-do little
cult that [ __ ] away now
oh my god it's Luigi right here go away
I don't think Wario is gone because they
didn't hear the door go oh there's the
door
Luigi was in two frames at once okay
shut up
Mario we know we did it he's getting a
little close they could not be there why
did I see Wario and it's like super
wrestling outfit
oh hi Wario like ooh I think he likes
get smaller the more I flip through
cameras like maybe hello hi Beach how
you doing hey Mario peaches over in the
other room maybe should go visit her I
hear some I'm gonna make it through this
night god damnit hi ru you look good
glad glad for you
I'm glad for you you look big you look
happy
no one here looks happy
except from Mario maybe maybe there's a
smile underneath all that evil okay
Mario got a little smaller I don't know
what that means
four am plenty of power this one thing
I've noticed I do have plenty of power
what is this baloney boy oh boy I don't
know what I'm supposed to do I don't
know if I'm so he's like a foxy
character and I'm supposed to spend time
looking at something looking at anything
maybe I got a fine peach look at her for
a little bit maybe that makes Mario
happy maybe he gets jealous that I'm
looking at peach now sorry didn't mean
do your girlfriend's beautiful wife I
don't know
okay dude okay okay this point I could
slam down the doors I got enough power
come what is with you Mario
what is with you what's your deal
god damn I think he might be a mechanic
words it's like what more I'm looking at
this closer the less yes there we go
five six am I did it night four done I
think happened nothing killed me
I didn't know why Mario was there I
didn't know why I'm gonna try to get
through night five to get this all done
it's cold in here
I have no idea what's going on no idea
at all they told me it was a day off why
am I still here I don't know hello did
you get the memo decided to close off
the factory there really is no way out
for you until 6:00 a.m. when the doors
open
yeah both doors are locked automatically
from 12 a.m. to 6 a.m. so yeah pretty
much gonna be there tonight
I'll just stay where you are as I'm on
my way to the factory now as a matter of
fact when I get over there I can try to
open the door from the outside but a
doubler will be able to anyways I read
something yesterday that might have a
connection of some sort to this factory
oh I read that if his soul want to
avenge have a revenge of some sort their
souls may turn evil then confused and
even go back to their old bodies
apparently they can get aggressive
against against anything that is
similar to once they died of Oh mothers
scare me off or anything but you haven't
seen Mario's body or something while I
was screaming yes what happened I don't
know I don't often scream yes to the
heavens like very rarely but what did I
miss
why did he get cut off huh run that by
me again you're sassy Suze oh hi Mario
you're here a little early
what is that that sounds like it's
closed goddamn this imprecise Mouse who
came up with the system of a mouse on a
goddamn couch would it really kill the
grumps to get a little table like right
here to put the mouse on
I know much karabast this is a bunch of
baloney dad I don't - shut up
if nothing is gonna kill me I'm just
gonna move on with my life and will them
down with this man I'm gonna go cry
myself to sleep Maura you're getting
very close to me okay how about you
don't I don't know if I'm supposed to
look at you're not look at you please
yeah that's a bad thing
hi hey what do I do what I do okay
Mario you screwed me up you son of a
[ __ ] I'm dead god damn it you son of a
[ __ ] Mario I didn't know I didn't know
what I was supposed to do okay this last
light it's gonna be pretty hard I'm
gonna end this episode here and I'm
gonna pick this up if you guys really
want to see the end of this it's gonna
take me a full episode is gonna take me
something more for his ice then I'm
outside the goddamn velvet couch so
either way I'm gonna try to finish it if
you guys want me to let me know in the
cabin I'm not gonna record anymore
tonight because I'm late I'm alone
goddamn windows creeping me out I'm
gonna go home so thank you everybody
someone for watching click the
annotations for videos that I've done
check out all the other frontman
siffredi self there's a ton of stuff to
see and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
[Music]
I can't move